hey this is presh talker
an evil warden holds you prisoner but
offers you a chance to escape
there are three doors a b and c
two of the doors lead to freedom and the
third door leads to lifetime
imprisonment but you do not know which
door is what type
you're allowed to point to a door and
ask a single yes no question to the
warden
you point to a door that leads to
freedom the warden does answer your
question truthfully
but if you point to the door that leads
to imprisonment the warden answers your
question randomly either saying yes or
no by chance
can you think of a question and figure
out a way to escape for sure
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
so here's a way that you can escape for
sure
point to door a and ask the question
does door b lead to freedom
if the warden answers yes then pick door
b
if the warden answers no then pick door
c
this strategy is guaranteed to work
regardless of the door type of a
so why does it work
let's work through the logic
door a can either have two different
types it can either lead to freedom in
which case the warden is truthful
or it could lead to imprisonment in
which case the warden answers randomly
let's consider the first case that the
door leads to freedom
in this case if the warden answers yes
to your question then that means the
warden is answering truthfully and door
b does lead to freedom
similarly if the warden says door b does
not lead to freedom the warden is
answering truthfully which means door b
leads to imprisonment that means the
other door door c leads to freedom
so you can see that if the warden
answers yes you should pick door b and
if the warden answers no then you should
pick door c
but what about the case where door a
leads to imprisonment and the warden
answers randomly
well in this case if door a leads to
imprisonment that means the other two
doors b and c lead to freedom so you can
always pick doors b and c in these cases
no matter what the warden answers
so if you pick door b when the warden
answers yes that will lead to freedom
and if you pick door c when the warden
answers no that once again will lead to
freedom
so this shows that logically
if you pick door b when the warden
answers yes and if you pick door c when
the warden answers no you are guaranteed
to find a door that leads you to freedom
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker if you like this video
please check out my books there are
links in the video description